Shazaam hey if wizards can just pass
their powers on to anyone with their
staff
how come Gandalf sent Frodo into Mordor
armed with only some light armor and elf
bread lambis bread the ability to shoot
lightning out of his fingers would have
come in really handy but that's
different video we're here to point out
all those little hidden secret not so
super noticeable Easter eggs from DC's
latest superhero adventure Shazam let's
jump into it of all the Snyder verse DC
movies thus far Shazam is probably the
least worried about actually fitting
into the continuity still the movie
contains a whole lot of references to
the wider world of DC heroics Billy
Batson's foster brother Freddy Freeman
has an entire bedroom filled with DC EU
memorabilia the Batarang obviously works
its way into the main plot but did you
notice all the newspaper clippings on
the wall they referenced general Zod's
attack on metropolis from Man of Steel
Wonder Woman and Batman teaming up to
help Supes take on doomsday in Batman V
Superman and Superman returning from the
grave injustice league cemetery Freddy's
wardrobe choices also reflect his love
of costumed heroes in one scene he's
wearing an Atlantis lifeguard shirt get
it cuz you know they they can they can
swim good Oh during their hero training
sessions Billy and Freddy are hanging
out in an old abandoned warehouse in the
background you can see big vats marked
with the logo of the ace Chemical
Company they're often associated with
Batman and DC Comics and are most
famously responsible for the chemical
that that caused a certain Gotham
criminal to transform into the Joker
probably led to some lawsuits which is
why they're out of business which is why
this warehouse is now abandoned you can
quote me on that
it's canon when Billy starts to become
internet famous Freddy refers to him by
a variety of different nicknames
including the red cyclone this seems
like a riff on Red Tornado a totally
different DC hero who's an Android that
can generate tornado like winds oh and
did anyone else notice that Freddy's
YouTube channel is named hero manager
probably just because pudy pie was taken
also hey not to be the bearer of bad
news but a lot of people
on the internet assumed that kevin
conroy the voice of batman from the
beloved animated series alfred analyzed
the militia forces was also the voice of
the toy that Shazam throws at dr. sivana
and the mall but no it's a pretty good
impression but that's the film's sound
designer Bill Dean as bets a whole lot
of the action in Shazam is based on
comic book storylines particularly Jeff
John's reboot of the character for the
new 52 in 2011 it's this version that
inspired the film's take on The Wizard
the rock of eternity
Billy's backstory and his foster family
and a whole lot of other details in the
comics just as in the film Billy first
arrives at the rock of eternity through
the use of an enchanted subway car Suzy
Batson mentioned briefly in the movie
has Billy's estranged father who's
serving time in a Florida prison was
also Billy's dad in the new 52 comics
his name is a nod to CC Beck who
co-created the character of Shazam then
named Captain Marvel with Bill Parker in
1939 mrs. Glover Billy's caseworker is
also a nod to a supporting character
from the comics the smiley face buttons
on her desk are an intentional reference
to Watchmen according to director David
F Sandberg good joke everybody laugh
roll on snare drums curtains but not
everything is exactly the same all right
in the comics dr. sivana is right eye is
capable of seeing and sensing the
presence of magic while in the film
it's where the magical creatures
possessing him are stored and though the
basic notion of Billy sharing his powers
with his siblings in order to take down
his ultimate foe comes from the new 52
these characters go back a whole lot
further than that
to some of the earliest Shazam
storylines Billy sister Mary has been
Mary Marvel since 1942 and Freddie
Freeman superhuman alter-ego usually
called Captain Marvel jr. in the comics
first appeared even further back in 1941
several things we can faintly see in the
background of the Wizards cave also
reference magical items housed in the
comic book rock of eternity the oddly
shaped fireplace that Billy first
discovers when he enters the cave lights
up in the comics to summon Shazam spirit
also if you look away in the back you
can see the
outlines of a magic mirror she's known
as Francesca in the comics and serves as
something of a guide and mentor for
Billy as he grows into being a superhero
even the bullies who harassed Billy and
Freddie at school the breyer kids are a
comic book shout out in the new 52 story
line a rich man named mr. briar whose
sons pick on Billy at school eventually
becomes possessed by the seven deadly
sins and let's talk Tigers you may have
noticed a lot of references to that
animal in this movie Billy has a tiger
insignia on his backpack
there are tiger ornaments on Shazam's
cape and in flashbacks a young Billy
just wanted his mom to win him a stuffed
tiger at the balloon dart game at the
fair
he later gives a stuffed tiger to a
scared girl to make her feel safe these
are probably references to talky tawny
an anthropomorphic talking tiger who's a
friend of Shazam's in the comics he may
never find his way into the movies but
that doesn't mean he's not great by the
way that school in the film is named
Fawcett central a reference to Fawcett
comics the company that first published
Shazam stories back then known as
Captain Marvel they ceased publication
in 1953 and first licensed their
characters to DC in the 1970s and
speaking of the 70s the movie opens in
the year 1974 with the villainous tad
Savannah as a boy that was the same year
that the live-action Shazam TV show
debuted on CBS
weird which transforms him in a flash
into the mightiest
captain
there are a lot of number 7s in the
movie actually now that you mention it
or I mentioned it well anyway it's been
mentioned dr. sivana discovers that to
access the rock of eternity he has to
write the seven symbols he saw as a
child seven times eventually he gains
power by freeing the seven deadly sins
when Billy goes to visit his mom he
finds she lives in apartment number 707
and perhaps most tellingly there are
multiple references to the universes the
seven realms one of these comes from the
alien worm mr. mind whom we meet in the
mid-teens
he tells dr. sivana that together they
will conquer the seven realms the wizard
Shazam also mentioned that he and his
fellow wizards had to protect all the
realms this also refers back to those
Geoff Johns 2011 Shazam comics which
introduced for the first time the idea
of seven wizards protecting seven realms
it's possible this will be explored in
any upcoming Shazam sequels it also
seems safe to assume that mr. mind and
dr. sivana will team up to create the
monster Society of evil which are
basically the Legion of Doom but
specifically gunning for Shazam one of
the mysterious doors leading to other
realms reveals a group of humanoid
crocodiles wearing suits these are
aliens known as the punku-- science and
one of their members herkimer is also a
member of the monster society before he
goes full Avengers and crumbles into ash
the wizard also tells Billy about his
former champion who used his power for
revenge and thereby unleashed the seven
deadly sins upon the world this is
probably a reference to longtime comic
book Shazam nemesis Black Adam who will
almost definitely become his rival in
future movies it's unclear right now
whether or not black Adam will
ultimately be played by Dwayne Johnson
as has long been rumored all I know is I
definitely want to see the rock in
Zachary Levi have a fistfight eventually
in something a few more quick things
before we get out of here the movies
appropriately filled with rocky
references cuz of the whole Philadelphia
thing the rocky theme plays when Freddy
and Billy run up the art museum steps
Billy sings along to eye of the tiger
hey another Tiger reference when he's
doing his lightning
and the cop car Billie breaks into has a
bag from Gino stakes inside a place
rocky eats at in the first movie and
finally just as in Aquaman there's an
Annabelle doll hidden in this movie the
director previously made Annabelle
creation so it's a running gag with
purpose when the cops first enter the
pawn shop she's down there at the bottom
left of the screen crew I am tired
hey let me try something Susanne nothing
yeah that makes sense
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]